A long time ago in Alaska, a dog named Patsy Ann watched the horizon.
Every day she waited by the bay for ships returning from an expedition.
Patsy Ann was a brilliant dog and she was very unique.
She was deaf.
She couldn't bark either, but she used all of her other senses...
...to know when a ship was near.
Patsy Ann lived on the streets.
Her owners did not want her because she could not hear,...
...so they abandoned her.
She found refuge in a fancy hotel.
Guests rubbed her back and scratched her chin.
Many people gave her food.
She became quite overweight.
She became very famous.
Visitors to Alaska were enthusiastic about meeting her.
They brought presents for her.
They liked seeing her and the feeling was mutual.
The mayor said, "Patsy Ann should be called the town's greeter."
The people in town loved Patsy Ann too, even though she lived on the streets.
They were willing to fight to keep her.
A new law made all dogs wear a collar and get shots.
The mayor received many complaints.
People wanted Patsy Ann to be able to stay.
One ambitious sailor got people to help.
Together, they paid for Patsy Ann to go to the veterinarian.
She got her shots and collar.
She could stay.
When Patsy Ann died, everyone missed the town's loyal greeter.
So the mayor hired someone to make a statue of Patsy Ann.
He restored the town's greeter.
Now she sits at the dock forever, waiting for ships to come home.